hola bienvenidos nuevamente bueno no no
voy a hacer una prueba de una identidad
trigonométricas lo cual es lo cual me
gusta bastante hacer aunque las pruebas
en ocasiones no son tan obvias debo
debo admitir que que no es algo que se
me había ocurrido naturalmente pero aquí
tenemos una imagen un dibujo y bueno
vamos a suponer que queremos averiguar
otra manera de escribir de escribir el
seno del seno
no de alfa beta alfa más beta donde alfa
y beta son dos ángulos separados
entonces si yo tuviera que si o si yo
tengo aquí el seno de 40 y de 50 grados
supongamos y yo quiero saber
bueno bueno de hecho esto es sencillo
porque porque sería el signo de 90
grados entonces pero si yo si yo lo
escribo como una combinación de la suma
de 40 y de 50
bueno pues va a resultar algo bastante
ahorita va a ser a lo que me refiero así
que bueno vamos a revisar la imagen
digamos que aquí tenemos el ángulo alfa
y este es el ángulo beta entonces todo
este ángulo es el ángulo alfa más beta
cierto entonces bueno si queremos
averiguar el seno de alfa más beta el
seno de alfa más beta en el seno de todo
este ángulo que todo puesto sobre
hipotenusa el cateto puesto de este
ángulo de todo este ángulo si
aprovechamos el triángulo rectángulo que
tenemos aquí el triángulo b hace
entonces eso es igual a b c b se lo voy
a poner acá arriba esto es igual a b c y
le pongo su línea de segmento veces
sobre la hipotenusa a b entonces veces
sobre a ver esto esto es igual al seno
de alfa más beta y bueno ya con esto
podemos escribir veces sobre ave de una
manera distinta ese es un muy buen reto
vamos a aceptar ese retoque y veamos si
podemos porque yo creo que la persona
que demostró esto tal vez lo hizo
jugando tal vez se preguntó lo mismo
pues puedo yo escribir a veces de una
manera distinta quizás quién sabe ahora
veces toda esa longitud es la suma de b
d +
efe y sabemos eso porque esta es una
línea horizontal
entonces vez m es igual a b d + b demás
efe así que bueno voy a escribir eso acá
entonces escribo esto verde
más
efe
todo esto sobre ave por supuesto sobre
ave lo único que yo hice fue reescribir
a veces cierto es la suma de esos dos
entonces la suma de este segmento es el
segmento es este segmento bueno espero
tenga ya sentido lo que yo estoy
diciendo en ok o que podemos escribir
eso reescribirlo como bb sobre ave más
efe sobre ave
efe sobre ave y bueno entonces verde
aquí tenemos el segmento bebé sobre ave
más
efe sobre ave bueno de hecho son razones
sin mucho sentido cierto bebé sobre ave
que qué puedo yo hacer con eso
efe sobre ave que qué onda con eso no no
no no sé con qué más interesante si yo
hago b d sobre b eso sería una razón
interesante cierto porque porque sería
un segmento sobre una hipotensa entonces
bueno veamos si podemos escribirlo
y aunque lo podemos hacer
matemáticamente esto es igual
eso es igual a verde sobre b
x
sobre ave y bueno qué es esto no parece
algo tan intuitivo cierto pero no escogí
no escogimos ve completamente arbitrario
no de hecho no fue así sabemos lo que es
verde entonces escogemos saber porque
quizás con el segmento b podemos hacer
algo de trigonometría y entonces verde
sobre b
forbes sobre ave es igual a b sobre ave
y tiene sentido cierto porque estos dos
términos se cancelarían si simplemente
multiplicamos estas dos fracciones y así
obtenemos el término de arriba y bueno
quiero quiero estar segura de que
entiendes que este este es igual a este
término de arriba son iguales ahora
hagamos el segundo término conocemos
efe no sería genial si pudiéramos
relacionar efe algo como la hipotenusa
de este triángulo rectángulo sino
entonces como a así que hagamos eso
digamos que aquí yo pongo el signo de
más
efe
efe sobre ave es lo mismo es lo mismo
que efe sobre por a es sobre a b sobre a
b y bueno una vez más simplemente
estamos multiplicando fracciones estas
se cancelarían e obtendríamos nuevamente
esto y bueno quiero que se entienda que
este término es exactamente lo mismo que
este término sin multiplicar las
fracciones eso es lo que obtienes y
ahora bien antes de seguir con todo esto
que hemos venido haciendo pensando
veamos si podemos encontrar algo más
interesante algo todavía más aquí
interesante en este conjunto de
triángulos y figuras si este ángulo es
alfa entonces bueno si tenemos la línea
a efe efe es perpendicular a efe cierto
y d es perpendicular a efe por tanto de
y a efe son padre las y ahora como a efe
es paralela a d
luego se intersecta ambos sabemos que
son ángulos internos creo creo que sí
se llama anglos internos entre líneas
paralelas entonces esto también sería
igual
esto es alfa también ahora puedes
imaginar una larga línea paralela aquí a
otra línea como a efe prolongada luego
esta línea de las corta y si te parece
lo confuso de lo que lo que yo estoy
diciendo hay un vídeo en líneas
paralelas en geometría sería bueno a
checarlo ahora creo que tiene sentido lo
que digo así que este ángulo es alfa y
esto es el complemento de alfa es
complementario a alfa entonces esto es
90 menos alfa y si este ángulo es 90
menos alfa éste obviamente estoy aquí es
obviamente 90 grados entonces sabemos
que este ángulo más este ángulo más este
ángulo deben sumar 180 por lo tanto esto
es alfa y para que tenga más sentido
pensemos en esto pensemos alfa
aquí tenemos alfa más 90 grados
- alfa más 90 grados eso que es igual es
alfa más 90 grados menos alfa entonces
alfa menos alfa es 0 por lo tanto nos
quedan 90 más 90 que 180 y sabemos que
este ángulo aunque tal vez se hizo un
poco pequeño
un poco pequeño el dibujo pero este este
ángulo es alfa y bueno vamos a regresar
a lo que estábamos haciendo hace unos
minutos que es
que que es verde sobre b b b sobre b
eso es cateto adyacente de esta alfa
verde sobre b
entonces adyacente sobre la hipotenusa
cierto ajá entonces eso es el coseno de
alfa lo voy a escribir acá esto es
coseno de alfa es igual al coseno de
alfa y ahora que es bm sobre ave que es
b sobre ave si observamos este triángulo
rectángulo el grande eso eso es el
opuesto de beta sobre su hipotenusa
entonces que esté todo puesto sobre
hipotenusa eso es el hc no entonces esto
es el seno de beta el seno de beta es b
sobre ave
eso es el seno de beta así que bueno ya
con todo esto coseno de alfa por el seno
de beta más y ahora voy a cambiar aquí
es más ahora cambiar el color rosa
efe sobre a efe sobre el segmento ay si
nos enfocamos en este triángulo
rectángulo de aquí es igual al cateto
opuesto sobre la hipotenusa para alfa
entonces tenemos aquí el seno de alfa
más el seno seno de alfa y bueno ahora
que es sobre ave el segmento a es sobre
el segmento b ahora estamos observando
este enorme triángulo rectángulo de aquí
a es sobre ave eso es el adyacente de
beta sobre la hipotenusa y que es
adyacente sobre hipotenusa exacto es el
coseno muy bien muy bien
ok kaká sea h coseno del ángulo beta
socata no lo olvides entonces coseno de
beta igual hemos terminado ahora para mí
debo compartir con ustedes para mí esto
es estos goles espectaculares elegantes
mágicos que es el seno esto es igual al
seno de alfa más beta que es el seno de
alfa más beta es igual al coste no de
alfa por el seno de beta más el seno de
alfa
el coste no debe está igual para mí esta
fórmula es hermosa parece ser un poco
simétrica o fácil de recordar vaya
cierto mayo parece y bueno no es algo no
es algo que salió así espeluznante no de
hecho quizás hasta lo divinas de quién
sabe no no sé a mí me parece hermosa
quizá hicimos la demostración ya con
este dibujo que parece algo ese dibujo
es algo allá está tiene un montón de
cosas y bueno espero batir había
deslumbrado veremos el coste no de alto
más vete en el siguiente vídeo